which of the equations are equivalent to
the following equation a capital letter
a capital l letter represents a matrix
and a lowercase letter represents a
scalar assume that the matrices are all
square fair enough so first so the
equation here is the matrix b times the
matrix a is equal to the matrix d
all right so let's think about which of
these are equivalent for all square
matrices b and a
so here they've swapped the order a
times b and we've already seen multiple
times that matrix multiplication is not
commutative it is not always the case
that b times a is equal to a times b so
we can rule
that one out
here
they keep the order this they have the b
times a they have the b times a but
they've introduced a scalar out front
they're multiplying the scalar times b
and then multiplying that times a or
actually we could do it in multiple
different orders as we'll see but just
to show that this is the same thing as d
let's do an example here and we'll do it
with two by two matrices and obviously
this isn't a proof i'm only showing it
to you for the two by two case but
hopefully it gives you a little bit of
confidence here
so if this is b1
b2
b3
and b4
and this is
this is
a1
a2
a3
and a4
we know what this product is going to be
we know what d is going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to which i should
probably have some more space than that
it's going to be equal to b
b1 a1
b1 b
1 a1
plus b2 a3 plus b2
a3 and i'm going to run out of space
here i can already see that so let me
actually clear that
and i'll write the next one in a color
that i can see on white or black
and we know that this next entry over
here is going to b1 a2 b1 a2
plus b2 a4 b2
a4
and then
and then this entry is going to be b3 a1
b3
a1 plus b4 a3 plus b4
a3 and then finally this last entry
second row second column
b3 a2
plus b4 a4 b4
a4 so that's what the product is equal
to and i'm sorry for having to switch
contrast right over here between the
white background and the black
background but let's imagine what
happens if we introduce an r
if we introduce an r right over here
then
multiplying this b times r is equivalent
to just taking the r and multiplying it
times each of these terms
and if you did that that's equivalent to
taking every place where you see a b
you're just multiplying it by an r
there's an r there there's an r there
there's an r there there's an r there
there's an r there there's an r there
there's an r there
now this is clearly going to be the same
thing as r times our matrix d our matrix
d was what it looked like without the
r's in it if you multiply it times an r
you're going to get this thing right
over here so hopefully this makes you
feel pretty good that this statement
right over here is true
over here this next one once again they
still have b times a but now they're
multiplying a times r and for the exact
same argument whoops for the exact same
argument actually let me go back here
and let me recheck the ones that i've
already checked so we know that this is
true now for the exact same argument if
you multiply a times r you're going to
have r r r r and so every place where
you see an a you're going to have an r
in front of it
so
r is
all of these all of these places so by
the exact same argument
by the exact same argument
the scalar being multiplied after the r
so notice we're not changing the order
of the matrix multiplication it's still
b times a but the scalar can come before
the b or it can come after the a or we
can multiply the scalar times the a and
then
do b times that ar so but this is
this is equivalent
now here they're taking r as a times b
so they are fundamentally changing the
order of the matrix multiplication
matrix multiplication is not commutative
so we can rule
we can rule this one out
now this one is interesting rb times ra
so let's think about it so this is b
this is a this is d
now let's think about what happens if we
put r times b is going to be we're going
to see r is all over there r times a
you're going to see r is over there
and then so for example this term right
over here is going to be rb1 times r a1
well that's going to be r squared times
b1 a1 and i apologize that it's kind of
getting a little messy right over here
and then the second term is going to be
rb2
times
ra3 which is going to be r
squared
b2 a3 and we keep going we're going to
put r squared in front of everything so
this is going to be the same thing as
the scalar r squared times the matrix d
so that is also
also true